bonsoir nouvelle édition du 7 8 en
direct si vous nous suivez entre 18 et
19 heures nous allons faire le point sur
l'actualité du département des yvelines
et avant de découvrir les principaux
titres je vous propose un chiffre un
chiffre huit mille c'est le nombre de
twizy rappelés en europe par le
constructeur renault dont le centre de
recherche est implanté vous le savez à
guyancourt en cause une fuite du liquide
de freins sur certains de ces
quadricycles électriques et un dojo et
potentiels pour les conducteurs à la
marque au losange évoque un problème
lors de l'assemblage en usine entre le
27 janvier le 1er mai 2012 ce qui
représente 1736 véhicules écoulés en
france les propriétaires concernés vont
recevoir un courrier en recommandé les
invitant à se rendre auprès de leurs
concessionnaires une demi-heure pour
vérifier s'il ya ou non cette panne si
elle est avérée et puis ensuite il y
aura deux heures de réparation
nécessaires réparation prise en charge
par le constructeur évidemment le
véhicule a été lancé il ya six mois il
est également proposé en autopartage
dans l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines aucun problème sur ces
véhicules n'a d'ailleurs été signalées
par renault voilà pour cette petite
précision concernant l'entreprise qui a
lancé son véhicule électrique il y a
assez assez récemment nous découvrons à
présent les titres du jour les titres en
images des travaux retardés au château
de versailles en cause est la crise les
budgets sont jeunes et la dernière
tranche du grand versailles initialement
à prévue en 2012 est reportée en 2014
des élus montent au front pour dire non
au nouveau mode de calcul du fonds de
solidarité de la région ile de france
info destiné à aider les communes les
plus pauvres parmi les villes d'île de
france qui tire la sonnette d'alarmé de
guyancourt la commune demande un
plafonnement de ces contributions au nom
des besoins et sociaux de ses propres
habitants il existe 26 centres de
planification familiale dans les
yvelines dont l'un et attrape ses
centres renseigne sur toutes les
questions autour de la sexualité en 2011
ils ont reçu 1500 personnes mais restent
encore peu connues reportage et
explications également en plateau avec
le docteur risque et la restauration de
l'église saint-pierre de plaisir est en
cours le chantier a démarré en mars ils
devraient se terminer fin 2013 l église
du xiiie siècle souffrait d'un problème
de stabilité au niveau du clocher le
budget est conséquent 5 millions d'euros
financé en partie par des dons privés et
puis dans cette édition il sera aussi
question d'environnement comme chaque
mardi et l'environnement avec valérie
horrible bonsoir valérie et au programme
donc de cette page environnement dans
une vingtaine de minutes ce soir oui les
mesures thermographique qui ont été
effectués il ya un mois et demi au sein
de cette commune de saint quentin en
yvelines ces mesures thermographique
permettent de mesurer les déperditions
d'énergie au sein des locaux personnel
et professionnel et nous l'évoquerons
tout à l'heure avec deux experts la
chronique environnement du mardi je vous
le disais dans une vingtaine de minutes
ce soir du côté de versailles à présent
du côté du château est les prévisions de
travaux sont revues à la baisse je vous
le disais en titre est la crise pénalise
les chantiers johanna soudry elodie mois
nous rencontrer la responsable du site
catherine pégard pour plus
d'explications
la crise financière sévit dans la france
entière et touche même un lieu jadis
symbole de l'opulence le château de
versailles le domaine royal est
aujourd'hui à l'économie et prend du
retard dans ses travaux initialement
prévus pour 2012 et la dernière phase du
grand versailles des moeurs hao plus tôt
en 2014 ce que nous faisons c'est que
nous différons le début de la seconde
phase de ces travaux parce qu'il nous a
été demandé comme à tous les
établissements publics un effort
financier cette année en raison de la
crise inédite qui frappe la france est
donc en fonction de cette crise et pour
apporter notre contribution
exceptionnelle comme nous l'a demandé le
ministère de la culture et bien nous
reportons le début de ses travaux de la
deuxième phase le château de versailles
prendra en charge un tiers du budget de
cette ultime étape dont le montant
global s'élève à 171 millions d'euros il
attendra néanmoins les subventions de
l'état avant d'entreprendre les travaux
pour l'heure d'établissement mène à bien
la première phase du projet lancé par
l'architecte dominique perrault à venir
une modification radicale de l'accueil
des visiteurs nous allons terminer la
première phase de choses schéma
directeur avec la construction du
pavillon dufour et ce pavillon du faux
comme vous le savez sera destiné en
totalité à l'accueil du public et au
bien-être du public puisque il y aura un
salon t il y aura un auditorium
catherine pégard président du château de
versailles depuis un an insiste il ne
s'agit pas d'abandon le grand versailles
est maintenu et l'offre culturelle
enrichie une nouvelle exposition vient
d'ailleurs d'être inauguré versailles et
l'antique à découvrir jusqu'en mars 2013